Film Courage: Your new book just came out
Now That’s Funny. I understand it’s 24
writers and you give them a premise, a situation
about a mother and daughter, instead of asking
them about their process because that’s
the fastest way to get fiction from an artist
is to ask them what their creative process
is.
Peter Desberg, Author: You know when you interview
somebody and you ask the about their process
you have no idea what you’re getting. And
a lot of people sort of romanticize the way
they wish their process was. Some will tell
you what they think they do. But the easiest
way to get at it (the most direct way ) is
to do it and we’ll watch. And these people
were so nice about letting us do that. And
one of the things that we thought was interesting
was the people we had had major credits. I
mean these were people who show runners, a
lot of them were show creators. All of them
at one point or another said “We’re kind
of nervous doing this. Because we have one
shot at this and then we are going to be compared
to really, really famous peers who will do
a better job.”
Film Courage: How much time did you give them
to work out this premise?
Peter Desberg: The average interview was anywhere
to an hour to two hours or so. And that was
it. They had their shot.
Jeffrey Davis, Author: That you’re reading
in the book is liberallyeditedso the
most important thing to us was the premise
making because you get 24 different stories
from one premise. But great questions come
out of it to but the most important thing
that we were sure not to cut their best work
and I think it comes across. And then the
little stories that we tell, the sidebars.
Peter: I mean we tried to put some of our
own insights into it and every once and a
while we’d see something really unusual,
we’d see trends like a surprisedly number
of the writers had graduated degrees in math
and science. And it’s like “Huh? That’s
weird for comedy writers?” And one of the
things that we found interesting is particularly
for TV comedy writers (people in the room),
they tend to be more story guys or joke guys
and the science math guys are almost exclusively
story guys (they were well organized) and
they were really good at plotting. A lot of
the people we interviewed also had stand-up
backgrounds and they tended to be surprisingly
the joke guys.
In fact there was one funny story that Lou
Schneider that wrote for Everybody Loves Raymond
told us a story that they were sitting around
the table and one of the guys grabs him and
pulls him under the table and he says “Pitch
this joke for me.” And he says “Pitch
it yourself.” And he says “No, you’ve
done stand-up. I want to make sure this gets
in. You’ll tell it better than me.”
Film Courage: So people knowing your skill
set.
Peter: Yes.
Film Courage: What if we were to give you
a premise, our own premise? I’m curious
how the two of you would work it out?
Peter: It would be brilliant, I’m pretty
certain.
Jeffrey: It would take a couple hours. Peter…feel
free to correct me…but my observation is
(I’ve talked about this a lot with my students)
is a good way to go out of a University (especially
as an undergrad) is with a partner. They are
much more likely to hire you with a partner
when you’re young and help you develop your
craft as a solo writer. I’m talking about
comedy. I don’t know anything about how
drama works. But I’m pretty sure that there
is so much cross-pollination now that it’s
the same. But the way Peter is…I got way
away from the story…I don’t know…what
am I on today, I have no idea?
I believe that it is really a bad thing for
people to have the same skills as their partners.
This goes toward answering the premise question
you asked. If both people in the partnership
have the same skills, I don’t see a reason
for the partnership. Complementary skills…Peter
has two things (one drives me crazy), he’s
able to put anything down in a draft, he has
no blocks. How he can even call himself a
writer without blocks is shameful. But he’ll
just put it down knowing it’s awful (it’s
not ever as awful as he thinks it is) and
then he’ll say to me “Can you work on
this and develop it?” Whereas I would rather
have dental surgery than do a first draft.
It’s painful for me. But I love rewriting
but Peter is capable of seeing structure in
his head (I think that it comes from his science
background), I’ll start anywhere in the
story and just let it write itself. And both
of those ways of working on developing a premise
or anything else are valid.
You know, one thing we’ve learned from this
book is there isn’t any one way to do it.
I don’t know if I answered your question,
but I like my answer better than your question.
I mean I have a little blabbermouth going
on. Did that sort of answer the question?
Peter: We haven’t gotten to it yet. But
I will throw in one sort of interesting thing
that we’ll get to. It will be foreplay for
the question.
Film Courage: Oh good.
Jeffrey: See he is trying to sell that book
[Peter’s other book].
Peter: There was a really huge study done
at Berkeley years ago. And it was just creative
artists it was architects, doctors, all cross
every field. And the two major findings that
they came out with were creative people have
a better ability to tolerate ambiguity and
really importantly they have the ability to
suspend judgment. And one of the things you
find particularly with young writers and they’ll
write something and they’ll immediately
get depressed saying it’s not good enough.
And one of the things that we’ve learned
and that for sure helps me is that I want
to get something down. We again like the old
Hemingway quote “Write drunk,editsober.”
So once you get something down then you have
something down then you have something to
work on. And I’ve never had anything that
looks like at the end like it started out
at the beginning. And so I don’t feel constrained
writing anything because I know it’s going
to get reshaped, reworked.
Jeffrey: I don’t have that.